foreign
it's sad to say but that's kind of what
people are calling us and we're calling
ourselves that people are fearful we
have an administration of intimidation
and fear tactics they will they will
take your job they will take your
livelihood they will and they don't care
um and we're tired of it you know we're
tired of living under that oppression
and right now our mayor doesn't love New
Orleans so the citizens in the residents
stood up and we do and so we're taking
our city back and we're going to save
Portland
competition was launched in August
against mayor Latoya Cantrell she's been
under Fire for unauthorized and
potentially illegal use of taxpayer
money for things like business class
flights and living rent free in one of
the city's nicest neighborhoods the
mayor's first class flight cost almost
eighteen thousand dollars the mayor was
also grilled on her appearance in
juvenile court last week to support the
family of a young man found guilty of
carjacking multiple women that's not
picking aside that's supporting a young
person that has made decisions
that puts him on a better pathway my
name is Eileen Carter I am the vice
chair of the Nola Toya recall I started
the social media
depends and I worked in a city
government for three years so I got to
really know the city and really be able
to understand the pulse of it and so
after Hurricane Ida I'm displeased and
I'm watching the city and I'm looking at
it and of course I had been in calm so
that doesn't stop and you're watching
this and I'm watching the breakdown of
the communication between the mayor and
the city and I'm like oh my gosh what's
going on it's really funny being in this
conundrum of you know having branded the
mayor and been her voice on Instagram
Facebook and Twitter for social for
three years it's like a tale of two
mayors I'm not kidding it's like you
know you thought you knew somebody and
then you're like
is that who I think you are like you
feel duped that's why it's so hard
because we I love the mayor I still love
her I don't think she's making very good
judgment decisions for the city at all
like to the point of arrogance American
Trail is facing criticism for seemingly
giving the middle finger towards a crew
of tucks float in a statement the
mayor's office didn't directly address
the bird flip saying cryptically Mardi
Gras is a time for satire and jest all
in good fun putting your middle finger
two residents isn't necessarily going to
get you cheers during a recall election
[Music]
they have 20 days to go through all of
the signatures to certify that we have
the number we do have the number and we
have a little bit of a cushion I got a
message
it ain't that we hate you you didn't do
your job and you're about to be fine
[Music]
teamwork it's just been a lot in this
Administration hasn't risen to the
occasion that we need right now
quality of life standards are just
diminishing literally like this our
crime was at its lowest 50 years in
2019. 50 year low now we're murder
capital of the nation we are here on
Mardi Gras day
standing in a busted up Street you know
what I'm saying that's been here and
this isn't like it's been here a week
this is like months and like years for
some people it's in front of your face
if you go drive in the French Quarter we
talk about busted windows there are
parking lots full of them we've seen
increases in crime of people coming
because they've been so waxed about it
we are not lacks do not come here we are
going to get you that's what the mayor
should be saying she should be on TV do
not come to New Orleans with your mess
our Police Department is going to stand
up and we are not going to take it and
we're going to ship you back from where
you came from
you know we're not asking for her to be
perfect we're saying you know what I
made a mistake or this isn't working
let's all work together and turn this
around but that hasn't been her response
I do I support it yes we do everyone
I've talked to seems to be pretty
it's not doing her best
um yes I support that I have a lot of
friends that have a bad time of petition
because they don't want retribution
against them but they'll vote for it
when it comes to an election I wish he
would do something about these potholes
we were talking about that in the car
over here we were like there's so many
bottles like I'm sorry to say that but
like what come on like infrastructure
man she comes up a lot with even the
tourists so even outside people know
about it so that's that's never really
fun for people to know about what's
going on and especially
with those kind of dealings in your city
I don't think she represents the city
well
[Music]
so their narrative what is what is
playing across America it's the easiest
one it's the race car she's a black
woman I'm a black woman too I live in
the city I want to be safe you drive
around with security you don't have to
put your trash out I put my trash out
and I wait for two weeks you know I
drive around in graffiti when I go put
my gas my head's on swivel you don't
ever have to pump your gas New Orleans
we are we're pretty resilient and
honestly we're tired of being resilient
we want to thrive you know we've been
resilient since Betty Katrina Ida and
you can go through the hurricanes in
between we're tired we don't we don't
want to be resilient anymore we want to
thrive and we deserve that and when you
focus on Common Ground you get things
done and that's our quality of life our
trash our lights our crime our our you
know our children so we're showing the
difference of how government can work
for the people with the people
we're gonna say New Orleans